california california california
the middle class famous tour is coming
to the left coast yeah guys april we're
going to be in san francisco april 4th
we're going to be in los angeles april
6. we're going to be in la jolla get
your tickets now it's a little bit of
stand up it's a little bit of ayg it's a
whole lot of fun do it
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
r u garbage it is it's a little show we
sit there with your favorite comedians
and we find out they grew up to be
classy or if they're just a big old
piece of trash
i'm your host stage foley coming at you
on a beautiful day we're down here at
antoni's basement she is off to spring
break with the girls oh yeah all she
packed was a two piece and a toothbrush
okay and i heard one of them say to the
other one as they were going out the
door if i don't come back with herpes it
was a waste of money
well you know but that's the weak
director she runs with a tight circle so
if you're down there in daytona keep an
eye out for tony that's where she went
that's course that's right she's not an
[ __ ] i pegged her for a myrtle beach
kind of gap
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me he's the ceo of ru garbage
kind of the head bozo around here so do
me a favor he's my boss show him a
little respect make me look good give it
up for kj kevin james ryan hey gang
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you rate view subscribe on
itunes full video available on youtube
and as you know those numbers are true
the roof
and then obviously
patreon.com
are you garbage closing in on our next
goal of 3600 patrons yikes where we get
real [ __ ] stupid check it out full
episodes a y full bonus episodes ayg
episodes of hard feelings live streams
the whole nine yards [ __ ] do it yeah
and having a nice quick shout out to our
producer sean the magic man makes us all
look good we had one of our little
drives in today palin around ripping
bernies listening to music trashing
people give it up for t-bone mcmuffin
toby mcmullen what's up dudes
man we got a real-life irish guy for st
patrick's day like we're the local news
who wanted to see the leprechaun say
yeah
over at gary's old town tavern
gang the long hair is not lying i'm
gonna get a net and catch him
rub his belly for luck
we could not be more excited to have our
incredibly special guest back with us
again today he's part of the family
pretty much at this point you know him
you love him he is the host of the
column terrell podcast do me a favor
give a nice irish cheer
to cali tea
tyrell
irish
hurry you go yup yup hurry
some real rabble rousers over there you
never did that hip hip width
hip hip hooray
it's not that's trying to score a coke
at a bar in dublin
anybody get your hair over here
yeah i can say coke in 12 languages
that's one
give me two uh
la coke
[Laughter]
leno's beers
what's cooking buddy happy st patrick
hey thanks for having me in is it
anything over there what's it yeah yeah
it's a big day and do you get this all
the time yes people always say
oh it's
people there's a rumor spread that it's
not a big deal in ireland i
honestly figured it was just like white
trash irish bricklayer [ __ ] no like i
thought it was like my family there's no
there's no burning desire within our
hearts to celebrate it but we do
celebrate it just by boot like bit like
the bars do it the bars
for your like and when you're in your 20
your teens and 20s and children yeah
we'll have the big parade and so it's
just a bunch of you know like i guess
high school marching bands and like some
stores
you know a couple of stores with a float
and here comes the pharmacies oh that
sounds pretty interesting
yeah this is you know just a floating
whatever like a tiger just like some
sort of gas station just built a giant
balloon of a tiger and then that goes up
the main street everybody looks yeah
that's a parade you know it's the usual
it's like the why a tiger
because that'd be like the logo the logo
of the gas station well like exxon
something like that you know what the
[ __ ] is yeah it didn't make it sound
like something
at the gas station
involved in this yeah big tony's gas
station
and the and he he'll sponsor the parade
what are your gas stations over there
they're always real weird petrol
yeah yeah the petrol station just jin
[Laughter]
no you're a [ __ ] offender
[Laughter]
now you're crosstalking toby cliffy you
get you get grilled all the time about
irish being irish this and that the
whole nine yards it's weird
[Laughter]
you know i hate when people bring it up
you know
i i was under the impression that it was
a solemn day in ireland solemn solemn
like sad you went to church
to the snakes yeah you paid respect you
went to church was it really snakes is
that the story
no i think it's a metaphor for a
non-catholic sweater snake really that's
what it is it's like patrick got rid of
the snakes and by the snakes they mean
like those dirty dirty protestants
no no they survived they were
cockroaches
you never read the same patrick on the
cockroaches
he's running around his room with a
sandal
aerosol cannon a lighter trying to kill
all the protestants yeah
that only gets told in dublin
after two after two am i brazil
you want to know about the real saint
patty
uh yeah so that's what he did he just
he's not even irish in patrick he's from
wales or france or something because
like a lot of he was a slave white slave
we had them
all right it doesn't get brought up
enough all right
that's not coming glad you're not bitter
about it
yeah i think he was a slave from wales
or france and then they brought him to
ireland a slave who was who was who
owned him just a bigger man
you know that's just some real jack guy
from down the street yeah that's pretty
cool patrick you're mine now that's just
the way take care of them snakes get
your little [ __ ] ass over here yeah and
then you're like protect me dad and he's
like yeah he's bigger than me too go on
go on what was what was the real who
were the slave owners in ireland
the irish crafters richer people just
richer people just anyone that was rich
with tom cruise and nicole kidman
yes i guess maybe have you i haven't
seen i don't think there was any slaves
in that movie at all i mean he was in
serfitude to a degree
yeah was he servitude yeah indentured
servitude yeah that was like the surfs
did you say that was surfitude
indentured radical
this shit's tubular dude yeah kalabunga
man cowabunga so what what what like
what are your parents doing this st
patrick's day i'm sure they'll just go
down to the local bar and have a couple
of pints of guinness that's imagine but
you know it's like pringles you guys are
big on pringles
every bar you go in
the small toe but it's a small tub of
pringles and body as a fat kid about
that when i was 18 i was in heaven what
are they talking about sour cream
they got the cheddar sourdough
sour cream they'll have the salt and
vinegar once which is just red i think
and then they'll have another flavor
usually maybe barbecue or something [ __ ]
really i'll tell you this pringles irish
potatoes all right what a weird
irish irish pub snacks are [ __ ] legit
yeah they're legit you walk in they'll
have like weird mints you know the
everton
ah yes right before a night of drinking
i like weird nuts
black licorice sir oh they got the and
then they got the bacon fries which are
just like uh potato chips that like look
like bacon and they taste like bacon
they're sold on that every every irish
person's childhood
well especially my generation you grew
up in bars because your parents would
just bring you to the pub sure and they
would like you'd be friends so your
parents would be getting shitfaced drunk
you drove by the way your parents would
get shift-faced drunk and you and the
the rest of the kids would just become
like a gang but yeah they just go go
play with the other kids dude i thought
everybody grew up in bars just and the
smoke just remembered to smoke
everything because they have a good
smoke inside so you just be running
around with these kids and then every
now and again you look for money and
your parents will give you money you get
like a glass of coke like you know like
a glass bottle of coke you get the
everton mints you'd smash it over
another kid's head yeah yeah who wants a
piece yeah
shank a kid and get his pound yeah
next thing give me your quid poor timmy
didn't see it yeah you're trading
everton mints like they're cigarettes in
prison
we we would do that after uh
softball games my parents played
softball okay that's where we would come
into [ __ ] like that but wait are you
talking about a bar that doesn't serve
food
most pubs wouldn't yeah yeah so it's
like it's like [ __ ] but they also do
still serve the snacks there's got to be
snacks at a pub
salty stuff to make a drink yeah and
there's a special type of crisp called
pub crisps you can't get them anywhere
else we call it chips crisp crisps
do they come in a bag i think like they
come in a bag yeah just a little back
now pringles comes in a
the short yeah
but shorter like have that yeah i know
what i pick i know what a little [ __ ]
thing of pringles looks like yeah that's
a regular size of pringles yeah
that is the little one
all the bar snacks have like silly names
like it's like pig twirlies and [ __ ]
don't that no pig
i'll slap you right now i'll walk i'll
walk bring me downstairs for this [ __ ]
this sounds like a gang by the docks
yeah yeah yeah big twirly's got them
that's what they got by the pig twirlies
let it be known this part is now by
order of the pig
he got long shank down at the wall
by the big twillies
the pig twirlies are funny yeah somebody
said our a friend of ours bridget on
twitter tweeted about us going to walt
disney world and said that we should not
go to walt disney world go to ireland go
to [ __ ] i go to ireland in a [ __ ]
heartbeat which uh hippie joe over here
said we could do that as one of our next
goals which i like that international
travel especially if you win your next
one oh yeah big spin yeah and girls and
on black they kept me up last night what
if we do what if we do that awesome if
we do hit we go right to the airport and
get on a plane ireland get all [ __ ] up
on pig twirlies for a couple of days
clear the schedule big man likes his big
twirlies
phony just heard about pig twirlies
uh 20 seconds he's already he's already
planning on spending 10 grand to go eat
them
what's it that's his that's how he
thinks they got pringles but smaller i
gotta i gotta get there
[Laughter]
when's the best time i think about this
far away land with snacks that i know
when's the best time to go to ireland
what city should we go to and would i be
accepted to accept it there as one of
the people they'd like you you're a
novelty
[Laughter]
what am i a neon sign you're a you're a
stereotypical american
and they'd all be making fun of me yeah
they'd be throwing pennies at you and
stealing your soul
putting the cats on me they'll all be
standing behind your back and every time
you turn around
they would just be slowly you'd be like
standing in an atm they would just
slowly mosey over and try to take
pictures with you
they're just [ __ ] leaning
why aren't you one of the twins on the
motorbikes
big filler ain't you yeah look at this
area holy [ __ ] everybody walking
god damn
we don't start food you would
there would be a turn around and go
you'd be get you would get called a big
contour that would be are you a vidcon
aren't you look at this big hunt
that's just but that's a nice i'm okay
with that that's nice they're not
they're not calling you an actual irish
guys are tough dudes i'd keep my mouth
shut while i was over there it kind of
yeah i want to rub my mouth
cold sores and pale skin but
yeah
i feel like they would fight it would
just go quickly
i feel like it escalated way quick way
more quickly than it did than at any bar
i've been in the u.s i think you gotta
people just start punching here's the
thing
everyone checks everyone is hammered so
that's why there's a lot of booze yeah
i'm like booze like going hard and like
i know it's like a stereotype but the
irish do really go [ __ ] nuts like
every night the goal is to get suck out
black out drunk puke wake up the next
day don't remember anything down there
where's this in dublin everywhere is
that we want to go to dublin yeah that's
where you grew up that's where i grew up
yeah dublin's awesome then you'd want to
go out like west to galway maybe go
south to curry the cliffs the cliffs
there's a bunch of great stuff try going
july or something because the home of my
forebears
okay really kerry that's what i said oh
yeah your family from kerry that's what
they tell me yeah yeah who knows that i
don't even know if i'm [ __ ] irish
good reason to leave
kerry not much not much going on not
much hope i go back i can revitalize it
yeah you could i could be like zelinski
i can go back and become the president
of canada
and have a feast
they'd be ringing the bell when you got
the town yeah they're hillbillies out
there no but imagine it's a it's a
village in ireland somewhere just full
of foleys yeah oh yeah everybody comes
like a bunch of broken park benches and
[ __ ] yeah the country broken chairs all
over the street what happened all the
seesaws
but yeah you have a good time like you
ireland for me it's not somewhere i'd
probably live
and
not know any of what like it's a good
trip the [ __ ] good tree yeah i kind
of want to go now i'm all juiced up i
don't know we want to go we want to do
uk shows and ireland shows they want to
do european shows
we can go back and forth uk to ireland
yeah it's not going to give us any
static are they there's a little beef
there
there's a little bit of history
maybe i don't know how it works for you
yeah yeah you're allowed
to go [ __ ] wherever i'll switch
access but you you would have to get
separate work visas i think whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa
[ __ ] molly mcguire donating
this guy's a
i'm trying to help you out yeah you have
to have a work visa for us to go over
there and do shows you gotta have a work
visa yeah if you can go get money yeah
of course have you this is [ __ ]
america's queen's out of control yeah
you mean
i can't just show up and work at a
foreign country
i thought it was different when we go
the other way yeah yeah
the guy who left the country once a week
ago come on
good for it can you pay me in bills you
don't let me work we're nuking you
do they use euros over there in ireland
ireland euros yeah nice yeah i already
know how to use euros you already know
how to use it for my time in france wow
how long i didn't know you were so
cultured yeah he's still got a couple of
things i'm going back i didn't know what
i was spending no i'm like that stu too
with americans like i never really
learned the coins
i just like sometimes people like oh
yeah it's like 45 whatever and i'm like
what can i get with this i never learned
less than a quarter i never i don't know
what i like that there's no there's no
there's no change over there right there
is yeah i thought it was for you
i thought it was two dollars was the
lowest no no they have two two dollar
euro
coins have two one and then like a dime
the usual [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah
they have a ten piece ten a quarter
twenty five no
twenty fives twenties twenty ten twenty
fifty yeah yeah i didn't [ __ ] with any
of that no what was the irish money
called before they switched over to
euros mashed potatoes yeah exactly let
me get two scoops on three
valuable
ah
come on that's pretty good
chelsea around this time of the year
i'll allow it will your mind will your
mom throw a nice feast on saint patty's
day she's down at the pub getting all
boozed up what are you talking about i
don't know the thing in the oven we
don't have any traditions when we were
kids we used to go in and watch the
parade for sure all right when you got
to like 20
or what like in your 20s you would
probably still just go out drinking just
go get [ __ ] up right yeah if not at
least the weekend around yeah yeah sure
so maybe maybe they already all went out
that weekend we did it like it was
[ __ ] easter
it was like we had my mom we had to go
to church
corned beef and cabbage the whole nine
yards we might have done churches we'd
have to know about what happened and
like the suffering and the this yeah
that was a lot of school [ __ ] you know
you like yeah when you're in school you
you'd cut up like shamrocks and [ __ ] and
hang it around this thing you would do
that like color a leprechaun take it
home put it on the fridge mom's painting
italian yeah that's it yeah chase the
tank get down the hallway the best so
patrick's day was great
but it was sloppy because everyone's
drunk all the teenagers are in town oh
it's a mess and there's a big carnival
in town so they got like the big wheel
and all that type of just really like
all sorts of rides you know that's
pretty cool but like all the kids are
just there drinking like vodka orange
they're all getting drunk in mcdonald's
at 12 like 12 years old and uh and 12
o'clock a day so it's like it's a messy
night you know yeah and every pub is
packed too so it gets too busy it's like
i like it 11 year olds bare knuckle
boxing in the street
you got to start young you know with a
big with him a griddle in his hand
what the [ __ ] i also was like oh that
sounds great you would hate you dude a
bunch of drunk kids in packed bars you
would [ __ ] hate it oh they'd be
debbie you don't even like sitting in a
booth at a diner they'd have me crying
oh yeah exactly
tubby tubby what do you want to be
the best they had we had an alternative
for a while which i loved which was
called guinness day do you ever have a
guinness day no that sounds pretty so
guinness day was awesome what they did
was for like the 250th anniversary of
when sir arthur guinness signed his
thousand-year lease on st james's yeah
brewery
smart man thousand a thousand years
thousand year lease yeah look what that
dude was doing back then well i think i
was playing hold on i thought he saw
this guy signed a thousand year lease
yeah at a fixed cost uh yeah yeah it's
up next week i'm gonna make a play at it
yeah it's going it wasn't it had to be
like pennies it was in um it was yeah it
was less than nothing he bought it for
like [ __ ] ten pounds they're still
they're still operating under that lease
today yeah yeah yeah i think they sold
off most of the land but they're still
operating on that at least yeah damn
they tell you when you go to the factory
they [ __ ] they mine i didn't [ __ ]
know that that's pretty smart 1802 1801
roughly like that so that's what
everybody should do
a thousand year lease yeah bring that up
bring that up next time you're gonna
renew this place
no we should do that in an apartment
that way in a thousand years
my our fa our family will have
an apartment why would any landlord give
you a thousand year lease
they're not they're landlords who did
[ __ ] uh arthur
rented from i don't know i think that
was the british government and they're
gone now so it's like whatever t-bone's
got some info what do you got i'm pretty
sure that the lease is uh not valid
anymore they just bought the land
eventually yeah i think it's more of
like a honorary type thing i got some
real good irish stats on arthur's day
also known as guinness step yes autistic
was awesome yes uh there was a 30
increase in ambulance callouts in dublin
on the night and more than 2 000
hospital beds were occupied with
alcohol-related illnesses
and that's that's on top of an already
high percentage of alcohol illnesses
just so you know yeah they were they
were
really good that's like yeah that's like
when lebron has a good game most of
those are beer bottles to the head yeah
of course most of them are underage kids
this podcast is sponsored by better help
online therapy gang we have a lot of
relationships in our lives don't we
kippy oh a lot a lot of friends that if
something ever happened to not a family
too you would drop anything you would do
whatever they want i'd be out the door
right now whose car we taking exactly
one of the most important relationships
you have for your entire life is the
relationship with yourself
and this month betterhelp wants to
remind everybody that that is the most
important relationship that you have so
it's important to invest in yourself to
try to take care of yourself you're
hitting the gym you're trying to eat
right you're trying to move yourself
forward trying to feel a little better
don't forget about your mental health
and better help online therapy can help
yes uh better help is online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to or if you like a
little peaky peaky by all means turn a
camera on nice uh give it a try and see
why over 2 million people have used
better help online it's much affordable
than in-person therapy and can be matt
and you can be matched with a therapist
in under 48 hours that's a huge thing if
you haven't
ever tried to find a therapist finding a
therapist is very hard dude you're
calling max the waiting you're telling
me that that that if to have a therapist
under 48 hours get you in the pool you
can then switch you can always switch if
you don't like them but you're at least
in the pool you're swimming you're doing
a mental health care and you might not
have those specialists in your area and
better help can uh take care of that
global this podcast is sponsored by
betterhelp and all your garbage
listeners get 10 off their first month
at betterhelp.com garbage that's
betterhelp b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com garbage do it let's talk about
athletic greens ag-1 listen it's no
secret that's my secret weapon you're
like popeye you're drinking so much
green juice i've been taking it i take
it to the gym with me i sip it
throughout my workout i leave there
feeling better it's an all-in-one baby
yeah the gut health the immunity it's
fantastic it tastes great and here's the
thing what's that bug
here's a testimony to how good athletic
greens is they sent us a free batch yeah
i use that uh-huh i'll use the samples
oh yeah but let me tell you this what i
re-upped yeah on my own use the promo
code
but i really like your beak on the back
end dude they got me hooked i love it
man yeah they're fine would not want to
be without it uh well if you're
wondering what is athletic greens what's
ag-1 it's one scoop of athletic greens
you're absorbing 75 high quality
vitamins minerals whole food source
superfoods that's what it is probiotics
adapto greens to help you start your day
right special blend of ingredients
support your gut health nervous system
immune system your energy recovery focus
aging everything you want to work on ag
one's got you covered
and if anybody knows about nervous it's
this guy
what are you talking about
uh it costs less than three dollars a
day so if you're investing in your
health it's way cheaper than you know
some mocha latte frappuccino water throw
it in you shake it up you're out the
door no blenders no [ __ ] vitamixes no
that crap i know everybody's taking some
sort of multivitamin i take two of these
one of these this over that
help this take it so your body absorbs
it ag one's got it completely covered
it's lifestyle friendly whether you
paleo vegan dairy-free or gluten-free
they got you covered you're a big fat
pig like me
uh to make it easy athletic greens is
offering travel packs uh and they're
gonna give you a free one-year supply of
immune system supporting vitamin d and
five free travel packs with your first
purchase all you have to do is go to
athleticgreens.com garbage again one
more time athletic greens.com garbage
take ownership of your health today by
the ultimate daily nutritional insurance
do it
no but guinness they didn't have any of
the kids so what they did was they had
this like random celebration and a mini
past six everyone would cheers a
guinness so they had this big
advertising campaign and then they
booked a bunch of musical
artists you know they booked you two and
all these like casinos and all these
guys you're talking about this like it's
small town [ __ ] no you got exxon you got
[ __ ] bono yeah we got it all big time
[ __ ] uh you two ain't cheap but what
they did so
guinness did this the thing and so then
let's say they had you two at like one
of the biggest theaters or biggest
stadiums or whatever but they also had
like local acts a little small bars but
they didn't tell anyone was that they
booked all the big names to also play
the tiny little rooms but they didn't
tell a single person that's pretty good
so like so people bought
50 like if a little 50-seater bar just
to see some local [ __ ] joe schmoe
[ __ ] yeah yeah and next thing you
know like if like a famous band just
walked together yeah just like kings of
leonard or something just walked in and
i was just like you always have to
perform and it was like blew their
[ __ ] [ __ ] it was [ __ ] it
was
and then it was so good that they ran it
for a couple of years they had like five
years it was every year
it was like my favorite [ __ ] thing
it was awesome but then they they got
rid of it
i thought the ghost of arthur was gonna
come get him yeah that's what it was he
was a proddy too but i i run in my mouth
that's the problem
there is a problem with arthur guinness
was a protestant so every time i'm get
it's like i feel i do feel conflicted
it's tough it would just be better if he
wasn't
i don't like i can't explain it but it
would just be better
it's just in your it's in your dirt bag
it would just suit me more
that maybe that's why there's
alternatives there's like murphy's and
stuff like that that's also great still
murphy's beamish these are all other
stouts that are really good how do you
know if you're a guinness man i don't
know i can't stand guinness you piece of
[ __ ] i can't do it man i see italian in
you
[Laughter]
like a nice white wine
oh yeah is that what you want don't do
don't be ordering wine in dublin no no
what don't chase me out yeah [ __ ] it no
well i like a harp can i have a harp
you can you know how to play it come on
what am i doing what about i cut cheese
with it what about a nice bass sale they
probably
i got them on that one that's funny i'm
sure they have a nice ipa over there
maybe probably now yeah maybe now yeah
you can do that yeah
or if you want to go fancy get a
budweiser
i remember i watched an old guy order a
budweiser and all of his buddies were
[ __ ] being like you believe this
hoity toity
it's an import build-wise
stella or twa it's all expense expensive
stuff yeah it was like if a beer was
like i don't know [ __ ] three euros
the blood was like 550 or whatever yeah
yeah yeah you were you're a big real
you're a blessing you're a big-time boy
if you're drinking budweiser with out
with the lads couple of butt heavy
that's crazy will you drink someone we
drink powers
or noise whiskey yeah yeah yeah kinda
i'm not really i don't have the pilot
for
differentiating amongst whiskey's though
so i'm just a [ __ ] dirtbag whatever
brown [ __ ] drink it out of a sniff
whatever brown horseshit you want to
tell me is whiskey i'm i'm i'll bang it
in only if you're running through a
decanter first
let's aerate this thing during the
lockdown i bought [ __ ] schnifters
really all that stuff and that was like
just to get it yeah i was getting into
it was like i just never i could just
never get past it i was just like it's
all just the same to me whiskey's just
like what were you drinking out of the
snifter
whiskey supposed to drink cognac out of
a snifter no you can still do it for
whiskey you can yeah i mean it worked i
don't think it's i don't think it's
gonna not let you yeah you could use a
cereal bowl too if you wanna
so can we go to ireland cause now i kind
of wanna go i'm all juiced up i've
talked you guys are gonna have a great
dude it's like you have that you have
the mind of a goldfish we've talked
about going and doing shows all of these
europeans can call it come with us no no
yeah we need him we need a sherpa yeah
we're going to need boots on the ground
so we need a translator yeah someone who
speaks the language of these animals
it's like the middle east guys when i
get pulled over by the local cops i go
don't and i'm speaking yeah i'm speaking
english to them but you don't understand
what we're saying
he's switching sim cards and [ __ ] back
and forth don't look them in the eye
don't look them in the eye
don't look the horses in the air listen
who's the fat guy drinking wine
what's he doing
[Laughter]
it's just a bunch of quick cuts what's
he saying i don't know
i'm american i'm a miracle what's going
on yeah a sleeping bag throwing over
your head
[Laughter]
oh man no you guys would love it i'm
always telling everyone that i loved it
man everyone i had a great time everyone
has a good time i went to such a young i
was 21 maybe so it was like [ __ ] me
and my boys were just gambling at all
those back yeah can my mom come
not with me
she could travel with us
no
she'll stay in my heart do that teach
her to hold the camera yeah right if
toby needs a if toby needs an extra set
of hands
maybe it's in the production budget get
my mom get my mom gripping yeah mama
how's she with a boom like mama yeah
holy holy leaning over with the boom
again no way you guys are well you got
trying to uh kiss the [ __ ] um the
blarney stone oh yeah i didn't do that
is that cheesy don't do that don't do
that no whatever you do people get hurt
yeah cause it's a stone that millions of
people kiss a year
people i don't think you would fit out
under it right honestly no offense no
offense but it's a tight squeeze the
castles are only so big
they were built a long time ago when
humans weren't when elephants weren't
allowed inside this is a cash grab
all over like
it's just around you like one of those
barrels
look like king kong in the middle well
you got it yeah so the
the blarney stone which is like a castle
and cork has like a
some random [ __ ] hole in the the roof
of it where you can you gotta lean
upside down like you're doing those like
[ __ ] sky crunches or whatever and
then you kiss this stone and it gives
you the gift of the gab which means you
just talk a lot but actually what it
gives you is uh cold sores yeah
that's actually what it is simplex four
yeah yeah so i wouldn't do that i
wouldn't recommend it i do know local
teens that have pissed on that stone
just to like
yeah as far as goofs
sounds like a real nice bunch of kids
over there well what do you expect you
come in here with your dollars
and your budweisers yeah yeah i don't
want you i never want to be that guy i
never want to be the tourists that's why
we always do anti-tourist stuff so i
wouldn't do that yeah go to a nice mass
see a nice catholic mass what have a
nice shepherd's pie yeah go out to the
cliffs smell the grass yeah all the
local stuff that's all taurus [ __ ] you
just named like the three things
go to mass that's crazy i've never heard
of anyone go to an irish mass no why not
because the most catholic church foreign
worst
time of your life just
against some [ __ ] prick on um on
jesus said to his disciples
i gotta imagine a world where that would
be fun
i'd sure
in america you go to some sort of black
gospel [ __ ] it
you know you make me want to shout out
something jazz band that's it electric
there you go what do you think what do
you think we got cool in the gang
playing over here
i've i've always assumed black church is
[Applause]
nicki minaj up there
a couple of slow jams on a sunday type
ones but can i just say one thing about
the blarney stone which is even more
[ __ ] up it's it's not
it's not within pissable range it's
because it's on there and eat something
so what they what they have to do is you
piss into an empty beer can and then
they will lower their friend in and
splash it off jesus that's even nice
that's above and beyond yeah that's
pretty [ __ ] up that's gracious yeah
and you'll only get splashback on your
hands these young kids well you know
we've all done crazy to be honest though
like there's no it's not like that just
lingers on a rock right
now the water will wash it off yeah
something like that
i'm gonna [ __ ] kiss that thing now
after all that [ __ ] and i ain't
ordering no budweiser
what are you going to do i'm going to
have a guinness you know and a stew a
couple of people
yeah this is all some pringles some
bangers and mash
some twiddle pigs i'm getting homesick
man what's it called yeah i'm getting
homesick too and i've never even been
there i want to go i don't know what was
called pig twirlies is that what you
said i don't know yeah i did it was
pretty good yeah that was made up i
thought they were real that's an
imaginary snack yeah i really really
really really really really what the
[ __ ]
this guy's good a little thing called
yes and
thank you second city you guys been
meeting up without us what's happening
here yeah you're talking to me like
audience members after live shows like
wow you really do stand up
you're better than i thought a couple of
workshops laugh isn't as annoying in
public either a couple of workshops
magnet theater huh you get that a lot
yeah that's [ __ ] there's nothing like
i don't really host that much anymore
but there's nothing like at the end of a
hosting show and just like come on you
should do comedy too i remember you got
that i get it all the time you got it at
new york comedy club one time and not
that long ago it [ __ ] it it was it
killed you and it gave me nothing but
pleasure yeah i saw the words come out
of his mouth and just hit you in the
head in pink mist man what's that
[ __ ] guy's problem i got it last week
too when i was because i still host
coffee he's already got hosted no it's
closed out hey you should do comments
sometimes
i just thought you were the bus boy but
apparently you got some pretty good
chops you're around it enough you know
you pick some things up yo that thing
you just made up had a lot of
very constructed i host i host michael
costa's new joke night at comedy club
which i love doing uh because i love him
he's fantastic and that hair that
happened last week
they come up and the way people talk to
you it's so
like even as comics it's like they're so
demeaning sometimes like like you know
like what we you know so what else do
you do and you know what were you doing
before this and and then do you know do
you do the jokes that say i [ __ ] just
did 10 minutes you [ __ ] [ __ ] come
out here i'm trying to have a smoke
trying to relax you're busting my
[ __ ] balls
[ __ ] [ __ ] and that [ __ ] prick
was with some [ __ ] smoke show it was
a friday night i [ __ ]
murdered and this [ __ ] comes up to
me after the [ __ ] show at a crowd
party [ __ ] yelling like we're at a
[ __ ] airport he's like oh yeah you're
really good you're pretty good too yeah
you're pretty good too yeah you ever do
you ever do stand up what the [ __ ] was
that yeah i do two seconds of crowd work
good baby
[ __ ] them you know what you're past that
give me those days
those days are over that's right
[ __ ] that every tuesdays at eight
o'clock
comedy club on fourth street come see us
ten dollar tickets
[Laughter]
i think they aren't that bucks guys uh
can we live stream
that's funny i believe he does i did i i
did that show a month or two ago i
bumped so hard that was like it was like
almost like i was like
those new joke nights are weird because
you got to get a fun rhythm of like dude
they really have to like you now what
you got to do is host and just do your
old
you murder i was and everybody else
looks like [ __ ] boozers but i
i was bombing so hard that they weren't
even throwing rocks tonight t-bone they
weren't even acknowledging that i was
like on i was like hello and i was kind
of like hello everybody here's rattling
and then and then i did a joke a doctor
drinking and i said hey i'm here it's
all at one point i was like this is the
worst honestly the worst set i've
probably ever had in my life it's crazy
it's like and i was like i'm not even
doing new stuff this is nice
yeah i told him i'm not even doing new
stuff i'm cheating
and
okay
yeah so that's that was probably on him
yeah
yeah so that was rough that was the best
one and then it's getting streamed too
so there's just like 10 other people
watching there's 13 people in ohio
watching you eat it yeah some guy in
papua new guinea is just [ __ ]
watching this guy what the hell
where's that let's go there you should
go to papua new guinea really have you
been there no
have you ever heard of it do you even
know what it is it's like the most
isolated
place on planet earth oh it's for the
cannibals right exactly you show up
they've done a harpoon yeah papua new
guinea would be a good little trip where
have you been give me everywhere you've
been
we talked about this a little bit on
your podcast yeah by the way check out
column's podcast of course he uh
much like us he risked it all got uh has
built his own studio he's in the
building baby he's in the building
[ __ ] a couple floors away from us so
go check them out support them it's
[ __ ] we just did it last week yeah so
if you haven't watched it already go
boys do numbers
the kids do a couple of zombies
yeah but thank you for all your help
honestly i couldn't have done it without
you guys you guys happy to help love a
guy standing up against the man saying
go [ __ ] yourself i love it you're like
you bet it all and i was like man i wish
i only bet it all yeah this guy
i bet a lot of bank of america's money
and i guess what chase is getting in on
the action too
i think they don't talk am i right
sir i didn't realize we were in the
podcast business yeah good thing there's
not some sort of a credit system that
they all
[ __ ] want they'll come knocking yeah
yeah yeah well check them out on paper
nice i like that please go check it out
you're getting a little deep with the
cards with the credit cards small
business loan
yeah
yeah that's that's one way of putting
that yeah and not but listen anytime
i've ever had credit card debt in the
past i've always paid it off so sure
this is 10 times higher than anything
but like you know what it's the same
principle right let me ask you this if
[ __ ] went south and you bolt it back to
ireland you're scot-free right they're
not going to come get you yeah no
there's no international thing for 20
grand or whatever yeah you're doing it
with training wheels then i really
risked it it would have to be i didn't
know that i'm kidding saying if you can
just go leave and start over in another
car yeah but then can we do that too you
guys could go back to i could i could go
to germany at least at least you guys
have somewhere to go live it's true like
my mom would rap me out in two seconds a
fat bastard's downstairs on a couch
he's smoking my sinks yeah he has money
for beers i saw
he was at the pub two nights ago i swear
it's got money for sandwiches
nice yeah so where have you been
so you know obviously the usual anywhere
in ireland anywhere in britain
uh spain is a huge vacation spot for my
generation of people in ireland where'd
you go what isla what you went to like a
visa i meant i worked in ibiza for a
summer one time actually what did you
just pronounce it with the beef
well i i always forget what i said lohan
yeah
what do you say ibiza ibisa it's not
ibiza anyway no it's ibita what's the
[ __ ] thing
but you took a pill and ibiza yeah he's
an irish guy it's not at first of all
it's not a vichy it's like posner
he says he is he says he doesn't say
ibiza
and ibiza
yeah but we we don't really do that i
think we just got like beta like i beat
it i beat it like i got beat to my wife
yeah yeah yeah
like yeah my girl got lippy so i beat
her
[Laughter]
what did you do there for the summer at
first we sold uh pub crawl tickets so
what would happen is going around the
beach like going to do that miami go to
different um hotels just go up to people
go hey wherever you're going after hot
chicks hitting them up to come to the
truck right yeah yeah trying to put it
it ended up that you can't go to the hot
chicks the hot chicks get them you got
to go up to like the sixes yeah that's
what i saw in miami when we were down
there they would go up to these good
looking dudes all like waxed up yeah
would go to hot chicks and they would
say hey come to this party today yeah
he's not a good looking you're yeah a
good-looking guy i was telling you
looking girl hey come to this party
other people like us are going to be
there yeah if he walks i'm saying he's
got to walk up to the sixers he's got a
hoodie and
i'm showing off my tits and i go listen
just buy a ticket i'll leave
20 bucks i'll leave you alone let's talk
about ladder ladder let's talk about
ladder baby you know what you got to do
what's that you got to get yourself a
little term life over there that ladder
a little bit of tl you don't want to
leave the family holding the bag yeah
i'm beefing beers and gofunds me those
are for bozos yeah you want to get it
the right way above board i've already
been warned what that i'll be thrown in
the w where the dog poops behind the
garage
you're gonna need a big poop baggie to
get you
if i don't get a little term life and
ladder can help no needles no doctors no
nothing three mil we're talking here
yeah that's cash when you apply for
three million no needles no doctors no
paperwork that whole not you know uh it
just takes a few minutes down the ac
phone laptop
to apply ladder's got smart algorithms
working real time to find out if you're
instantly approved yeah there you go no
waiting around yeah who wants that you
okay yeah a guy with coffee breath
[ __ ] what if i was sitting there
waiting to watch the clock ticking on
three mil whoa
wait
uh issued by long proven histories of
paying claims rated a and a plus by am's
best i don't know what that means but
these guys came to play if they're
dropping it sounds technical you know
it's serious so go to ladderlife.com
garbage today to see if you're instantly
approved that's ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com
garbage ladderlife.com garbage do it
let's talk about babel
let's talk about babel
bodybuilding still
you want to learn a new language it's
the easiest way to do it it's like
learning language with bite-sized pieces
and they don't use a.i let's don't
forget terminator huh yeah yeah when you
jammed up yeah so come back from the
future to try to teach you portuguese or
something you want to learn you want you
want to learn french from somebody with
red eyes
face falling off
uh
now thanks to baba the language learning
app has sold more than 10 million
subscriptions it's addictively fun easy
way to learn a little new language they
make it perfect to learn language on the
go uh teaching method has been
scientifically proven to be effective
with babble you can choose from 14
different language
languages including spanish french
italian german nice uh and whatever they
speak in foleyville right now if you
purchase the three-month battle
subscription you'll get an additional
three months for free that's six months
for the price of three just go to
babel.com use promo code garbage that's
b-a-b-b-e-l.com code garbage babel
language for life not back
back to the show
i won't show up
yeah exactly but then we just stopped
them we ended up becoming friends with
all the people on the strip all the
bouncers because so you're not allowed
into a bar with your own alcohol but we
became friends like as in so you can't
leave one bar and then just walk into
the bar across the street but because we
knew the bouncers they would let us go
in yeah but we lived right on the strip
so we used to i mean when we budgeted we
had a budget we had like seven euros a
day type of finance yes so we would what
would you do what's the point of going
yeah because you're a young dumb and
full of calm yeah it's nice right you're
an amita you know you're hanging seven
bucks a day get you in a beast so it
used to be
thailand there used to be a 750
milliliter uh vodka bottle you could buy
for 350.
and then there was um you could buy like
a week's worth of pasta and sauce and
you could live off and eggs and you
could probably stretch that out to about
twenty dollars for the week you know
twenty euros dumps in that pocket and
then we and then and then we had orange
juice every night it was just pasta the
worst sauce nothing else and we would
eat vodka and we would drink vodka and
orange juice and so you would get drunk
on the vodka orange just go to the strip
go into all the bars then you'd run back
to the house fill yourself back up with
vodka orange just go back out and then
we did it that's real dirtbag [ __ ] if
you're making your own drink you're
going to try to dance with chicks with a
screwdriver
[Laughter]
we had like a big burger king glass yeah
you're dumping dumping the ice out
hey like leon from
hey baby can i get you a drink
i'll be back in 20 minutes
stay right here give me that cup
no no no they don't do food i brought
this from home
tupperware
yeah that was it man hey can i just you
ladies in some week old spaghetti
and eggs and eggs
oh man man i wish we had spaghetti
spaghetti with scrambled eggs that's a
tough look dude
yeah well we just you just survived and
then you did a lot of ecstasy a lot of
access yeah that's where did you get the
money for that
that's what you're saving all the money
oh my [ __ ] screwdriver sometimes what
you do yeah you'd probably buy like 50
and try sell 20 of them if you could and
that's the cheapest
again they're like euro a euro each so
you'd probably take about eight of them
because if you ever got if you're a
lucky you could get tickets to the
biggest nightclubs like you'd meet reps
and they would give you tickets and the
tickets are usually like 80 bucks but
wait what's a euro each the pills
are not great
if you went to one of those nightclubs a
bottle of water is 15 a euro
a drink yeah drink is like 25 euros so
once they get you in there you're [ __ ]
you had to you had to do ecstasy it was
it was like it was good financing it was
to do this drugs otherwise you you'd
honestly i didn't even want it otherwise
you're not i didn't want to fail i
didn't want to feel loved with strangers
i wanted to spend 20 on a beer so you
had to just honestly to survive you just
had to dude and it was like all chopped
up with speed and stuff and we had a lot
of bad come downs me and the guy just in
the room who's the guy he can't just
drop me and the guy oh the guides my
friend andy we we went together so we
just had like a two-person room in some
hotels same room same room single beds
in a hotel
uh
no it was like an apartment complex okay
we just rented it for like six weeks or
whatever sounds like a nice little
vacation yeah we should go there yeah
all right let's see we got to do
something cool we got to do some
questions
questions you said you had some
questions for us
i have a feeling like few of these might
have been asked in the past so here we
go do you ever use a bus ticket to get
food out of your teat
jesus
i'll use i'm a big matchbook guy to get
i'll use anything
to get it out of my teeth but a bus
ticket
like a subway car
subway car is dicey because you always
i'm like i've swiped this 10 thousand
yeah i use this well i just said bus
ticket because it's more universally
accepted but matchbooks were bigger with
my dad my dad was what's up
like a book of mine
okay yeah he'd sit there sideways
watching tv when we were kids dig back
in there and he would go through like
the whole thing like he would just
oh he'd use the matches no no he would
rip little sections of the of the thing
off yeah there's nothing better than
that corner again
there's a technique to ripping up
something that's too thick
that's a it's a horrible skill to have
yeah the dirtbag if you're like i'm
really good at ripping things into small
pieces to fit inside my bed yeah
you see
quarters of the way so it's like a
little pocket knife you want to peel
like you cut your nail it was like
hanging off on it yeah yeah yeah and
then like peel it halfway peel it back
and then dig like that
there's so much bacteria in there those
things that i'm still here
those things that they have now which we
just got a whole bag of them which are
fantastic they're half dental floss yeah
half ice pick yeah i told you about them
this is why they're the glide phenomenal
the glides it's orgasmic when it goes in
one dude one of you two when talking
about flossing talked about sniffing it
and i did that bad news and now you're
under investigation for war crimes
because that [ __ ] is [ __ ] [ __ ] up
it's the worst thing you've ever smelled
in your life how do you guys not know
the bad tooth taste in your mouth
it has like a bacteria kind of like
like it tastes like a cavity you don't
know what i'm talking about you're
smelling your [ __ ] dental floss what
does it smell like
[ __ ] satan's [ __ ] dude it's not
good yeah it's real bad man a couple of
piggly twirls yeah i used to did you
guys ever have braces no yeah i did you
had race but getting like when they
would clean them or getting them off
just
because there's just like stuff stuck in
there yeah the smell of a retainer oh my
god it could it would knock out a horse
man
oh there goes skittles yeah exactly yeah
that [ __ ] was brutal yeah that's a good
one what else you got all right let me
let me these are good we're gonna cut
them out of this episode i'm going to
use them on another episode uh have you
ever intentionally exercised in jeans
uh no and i don't mean like you showed
up to the gym and you realize you forgot
i forgot like you're like i'm gonna go
work out that's also a garbage look but
intentionally gone nah i'll just wait
i'll just wear the jeans no you see that
a lot at the planet fitnesses the blink
fitnesses yeah it has real suspect
energy vibe
it's like
anytime you see a guy running even on
the street in jeans you're like you're
running from something yeah that's a bad
luck yeah yeah it's not good but we used
to play like peewee soccer and stuff and
like in jeans things like that yeah the
guys that we would play soccer with were
rough like they'd be substitute smoking
on the sidelines to be head-butting the
referee
there'd be kids yeah it'd be local
fights like we would show up and if it
was like a local how old are we talking
here anywhere from like 11 to 16.
smoking smoking yeah yeah yeah you'd
just be on real athletes out there [ __ ]
yeah you were like yo let give me five
minutes will you be smoking in the back
i've i've had cigarettes playing defense
yeah you have played defense dude
because the ball is up the other end
you're like you know you and the mr goes
all sides or whatever yeah you you'd be
hanging out just talking to your parents
there yeah but you know did you have
like a mom that like brought orange
slices and you went to like pizza after
the game
no no women aren't allowed
on a pitch that'd be crazy if if
someone's mother was involved in are you
serious kind of yeah ah my mom [ __ ]
ran all that stuff it was great
americans are weak
yeah that kid's got a point yeah you did
the rights on that one we did it was
rough 11 year olds got to start smoking
yeah we would smoke and then sometimes
you'd show up and you're just like
playing in jeans
that's insane to me yeah that's real
playing with adults yeah but then 30
year old yeah and then there'd be local
local guys who were probably in their
mid 20s are just hanging out at the park
just on like a saturday morning i don't
think that happens anymore that used to
happen i feel like the park you were
just there was just people around the
park probably shouldn't be there the
park was busy yeah and it'd be to be
like a
black mark from someone who had a little
fire somewhere sometimes you show up to
play a sucker pitch and like half the
pitch is burnt out because it's like a
local teenager
[ __ ] burning witches the night before
people bring their own shopping cart and
then flip it so they have like a little
seat to watch the game is this is this
not
why did i just bring a little seat
what well [ __ ] what are they the
queen of england
why would you yeah i have a good of a
good shopping cart right here what do
you think just stole this from aldi what
do we do exactly
i imagine you're playing like bombs or
dropping around around i imagine not a
single blade of grass on this pitch
there was a picture all dirt and shards
all the broken bottles we used to show
and then it would get dry in this in the
summer so then the pictures would be
rock solid like [ __ ] concrete so then
like you couldn't even like if you're
playing soccer you couldn't even slide
her in otherwise your [ __ ] kneecap
would be on the other side of the field
man that was no no shot there were nets
in the goals there was there was nets
often
i imagine jogging
it's like a public park the nets aren't
kept up
you know they let the netherlands climb
in [ __ ] oh yeah they'd just be stolen or
ripped down or sometimes you just show
up and just be like
somehow even though it's a metal goal
posts that are in the ground somehow
they will have burnt them sometimes
somehow
a an infl like something that's not
flammable will have been burnt to the
ground by the local teens
so then you're so then you're [ __ ]
you're getting some after school
activities yeah
yeah you burnt down the fire hydrant you
believe that so so you're you're under a
fire truck torched it yeah you're under
age four like your 14 year old soccer
cup game would have to be played with
like people's higher extinguishing
people's sweaters as goal posts instead
and then the ref was like i think that
was a goal and you're like what yeah
that was just my childhood yeah jeez i
remember one time at lacrosse camp the
air conditioner didn't work
holy [ __ ] i freaked out i requested a
room change
i remember one time our school bought we
were in sixth grade and they bought uh
a uh a metal soccer net right like so i
guess the idea of prison [ __ ] so i guess
the idea was like we're not gonna have
to redo the
it was like a cage you know it ended up
just being a cage without one side on it
well we pushed it up against the [ __ ]
building and would put
two people in there and have like a
[ __ ] full-blown ufc match
and if they would try to get out we'd be
[ __ ] like reaching through the cage
and like prodding them and stuff that's
awesome
and then they moved it away from that
and then we have two stray dogs fighting
yeah dude it was [ __ ] mayhem well you
send kids out you send you know 12 year
olds out with for an hour long recess
we're going to get into some [ __ ]
shenanigans yeah of course this is at
the height of the yeah
do you which you didn't guys just didn't
burn things we burned we did burn a lot
of stuff just like we're a big burning
country yeah
it's it's it's chilly
[Laughter]
yeah yeah we burned everything but i
even but my neighborhood's changed a lot
since i went home recently and there was
like
weird they moved on the bank there was
like there's like a guard there's like
you know the locals have taken over the
park it's a big enough park but they've
like have like a little gardening area
and things like that where people just
like plant like
parks that's nice yeah that's what the
park's supposed to be and like i went
for a walk with my mother i was like
dude when i was growing up there's no
way there wouldn't have just been like
20 kids egging houses
drinking cans of cider
all those roses would have been kicked
the [ __ ] out just just walking along and
kicking something ain't too shabby yes i
gotta be honest
yeah you ever you ever punt the daffodil
oh
dude
take the head of a rose clear off oh
it's someone's expensive roses yeah just
ruining [ __ ] for the sake of ruining
yeah you borrow your dad's driver you
head up there
yeah i don't know [ __ ] by ripping a
branch off
for no reason just like all art local
kids like make art now and they have
like like a little art exhibition in the
park it's like what type of what
happened what happened to all the guys
who would just like stab people like
what though what is this they're all in
[ __ ] jail yeah i don't know i guess
they just those their kids couldn't
afford the neighborhood so then they're
yeah they all got [ __ ] booted out
good yeah listen
yeah gentrification there you go
well now it's here now yeah i'm just
complaining about it i'm complaining
about a nice walk with my mother yeah
the neighbor has really gone to hell
hasn't it ma
see that vegetable garden over there
goddamn disgrace
we do a couple here uh from the old that
patreon guys when you sign up for
patreon we will answer your garbage
question
this is from braxton and we've talked
about this a little bit i'd love to get
your take what are your thoughts on the
aluminum beer bottle
oh that like it looks like plastic no
it's it would be aluminum like a can
yeah it's like the big like they sell
them in like games or whatever it'll be
like a miller light or like a bud light
yeah i know the bud light ones where
it's like a twisty yeah but it's like
it's like it's shaped like a bottle but
it's a little it's aluminum cans cause
you can't smash it over somebody's i
know i don't like them they always get
given to me at weird events
real regatta vibes yeah
they bug me uh to drink out of i and i
can't see what's in it
that freaks me out because you can't see
what's in it at all let me tell you it's
not like you're buying blind though a
bottle of coke you have an idea at least
it's some of it's this even a dark
bottle of beer like a bud light you can
see where you see that's probably how
they get you because then you end up
banging them back and you go i flew
through them they're ice cold
when they're cold they get screaming
cold and for a while bud light had that
bud light lime which i don't know if
they still have yeah but dude you get a
couple of those [ __ ] things ice cold
you got very philly there they go down
real smooth you get a couple of doze
you got eggs in here uh i'm a big fan of
them at like a game or an event or
something but you know i then you were
like they're trashy and then i i thought
they're [ __ ] real i always thought
they were classy
no i don't yeah they never thought about
it i just go oh look at this you know
because in my head i've paid to be
somewhere when they're giving that to me
i wanted aid to be at a sporting event
so i'm like i had the 50 bucks for the
tiki yeah it means i got a little bit of
cash i'm
but i yeah i don't know i don't like now
now when i see them i think they're
trash i don't want them near me i can do
a bottle i can do a can how much can i
want to go back to camp i'm
in [ __ ] brooklyn that was literally
almost kicked out of a car a can
well you don't like cans what a little
kind of coke like what is this oh
sporties no it's not nice
it's the it's like a cake it's a little
more ever vested hold on a can at a
party it's the contrast
is different but when you're on the go
it's got to be a [ __ ] bottle like
this and i also want to go on record and
[ __ ] say this right now okay i don't
like the [ __ ] skinny can [ __ ] no
that they're trying to pick up on people
they can absolutely [ __ ] the [ __ ]
truth
get out of here with that [ __ ] i feel
things just put it in a regular [ __ ]
can no mike the new thing is that was
branding they they've
like my local cvs if you want to kind of
coke they only sell them in the long run
i flip from bottles to cans all the time
it's like i'm like all into like bottles
of bud light now i'm just like all into
the small cans i love a can of beer dude
a [ __ ] cold can of beer yeah you pour
it into a glass baby gentleman no i love
that i love the i love the [ __ ] speed
bump it gets on the way out of the on
the way up yeah you know drinks a good
can of beers baldwin and the departed
when he's golfing when he's hitting
balls oh he's flicking that [ __ ] butt
can oh it makes it look good nice so
does will ferrell and anything must go
what a good movie
i was out recently at like a party or
some [ __ ] and they it was a funeral
actually you know i think about whatever
whatever way you want to phrase it you
know what i mean and uh i said this
rager a couple like they hadn't they had
for my dead aunt i took eight pills of
ecstasy for the viewing yeah he was the
loser in the box i'm talking about a
real wet blanket at a party yeah i was
trying to [ __ ] around i wasn't chopping
i'm gonna put our dirt on her eventually
or what's the deal i was chopping up on
the [ __ ] on the coffin
with the credit card yeah you want first
i'm just
[Laughter]
got the body holding up their finger um
but they
the person was supplying beers
and they they had the corona premium you
know that and everyone was well everyone
was in the skinny cans no they're
bottles they're just regular but it's
corona premium
and everyone was like oh look at
everyone was like yeah we're so fancy
and then i googled it it turns out it's
corona extra light so they have corona
and then they got corona light then they
got corona extra light is that the
really low calorie one yeah it's like a
62 calories they named the premium and
they kind of put it in like a fantasy
fantasy
yeah yeah so me and all these other
idiots are like oh look at us with the
good [ __ ] yeah and it turns out it's
actually the worst [ __ ] yeah doesn't get
you [ __ ] up but you call it premium
your [ __ ] dumb white trash head goes
well
i went out with my younger cousin and
his boys one night down the shore
and my cousin that you met that we were
hanging out with it was him and all his
boys i'm like i'll go out we went out i
was like already [ __ ] up and guys i
got what his friend's like i'll buy a
round of beers and he turns around with
like six michelob ultras i'm like what
is this dude you can't say i'm gonna buy
a round of beers and they're michelob
ultras but that's just like what the
young yeah in shape kids are boozing
with didn't even they're very carb
conscious yeah yo you guys want to get a
bucket of zimas that's what i was like
dude what i'm like demons got sugar in
them they wouldn't even give you a heads
i don't even get to pick like hey what
do you want wow you're buying a round of
drinks hey well you know hey toby what
do you want this that or you got to go
something a little more middle of the
road though yeah hey i got six bud
lights all right michelob ultra that was
the first and last time i ever had one
yeah
i've fallen for that [ __ ] again a nice
corona though it's pretty good big
corona guy
in a can ice cold with a line a mexican
beer with mexican food is like a
yeah
and some tacos
oh a couple of tacos and a corona man oh
yes
it does it hits dude it hits right chips
and salts on the table ain't nothing to
say
yeah they should do that with every
restaurant should always be chips and
salsa in a middle eastern place anywhere
it's so much better so much better than
bread and i'm saying that as a fat guy
chips and salsa should be standard on
the table everywhere fair
all right let's do one more then we got
to ramp it up cool this is from chris uh
new patreon long time listener did you
have any tenured crazy or homeless
people in your neighborhood growing up
ideally with a name like that's [ __ ]
cracker jack that's just al
yeah we
so crazy
or street per everybody sounds [ __ ]
crazy anybody under the age of 18 seemed
a little wonky yeah dude there was a lot
of i don't know if crazy's right word
there's definitely some sort of
deficiency going on and um
but we i don't we we didn't really have
in this in the city of dublin there was
a couple of famous homeless people yeah
there's not many there's only a few
really really a lot like back in the day
i figured he'd be falling out of windows
over there
[Laughter]
um
yeah they just
we just don't have many homeless people
i guess but like
it's more like a drug problem i guess
but we didn't have like like yeah we
didn't have like a fun hobby yeah called
jinxie or whatever you lived under the
bridge yeah there was a couple of local
like you know that's just jojo you know
you know the people that were like
they were they were in their 50s but
they had the mental capacity of like a
15 year old sure so those guys would
show up on their bmx or whatever and
then you'll be like oh it's rocky you
know and his name was [ __ ] jim
but uh yeah we had a few of them but
nothing's nothing yeah
we had one in the suburbs
that we called on the rich borough bum
because he lived in richboro and he
lived behind the dry cleaners sounds
like jeepers creepers and then the idea
was he uh which borough there was like
there was like a murder mystery
it's an ipad the idea was like he was
like the out [ __ ] there was like the
he was the son of this like rich family
who was like you know
they were like oil or something i don't
know what the [ __ ] is this true or do
you guys made this story no this was the
lore i don't know it really could have
been
they just said he was crazy and like
like you would see him and you would
like we'd be on our bikes and we'd
[ __ ] peel out dude wanted no parts of
this guy what he'd be just walking
around the side of the road yeah just
wandering around oh there's the bum
you know did he we used to wear it buy
him sandwiches and stuff what do you
wear winter coats in the summer
yeah
oh if a guy's got a coat on in the
summer in new york you cross the street
and you can tell by the shoes too there
was a crazy guy that i used to see when
i was in college in the city and
he was i guess he was notorious he was a
[ __ ]
i guess like a sweater sweater beast or
whatever like he would just like he
would wear
clothes like a sweater piece he would
wear clothes like like like he was about
a sweater huh you know you know when
they're about to up charge you on the
airplane so you go hold on hold on put
all your clothes on yeah this guy
i saw a carry-on guy he it was like
something out of a sitcom like and he
would just have every piece of clothing
out and then he would sit outside in the
sun if it which is rare but it would be
like a coffee shop and he would sit in
the sun just faking it in but it wasn't
like
you know i couldn't wait for the
wrestling match no he was a heavy boy
too but yeah he was he was nuts he's
just like i don't know that was his
thing just like sweat the [ __ ]
certain conditions i think you can't
feel the outside yeah certain mental or
uh things or if you're on the on or off
medications you don't feel the heat
sensation yeah that's why like the whole
a lot of the homeless guys if it's like
schizophrenia they have like 50 jackets
on there was a makeup look
where i grew up not that many but in the
city you would know them because not
that many yeah new york's insane dude
what if you were him and you just didn't
realize it is that what you're saying
yeah yeah everybody's talking like hey
that that homeless guy got it at home
was crazy i got a [ __ ] together moved to
new york and opened up a podcast this
whole thing is like this shutter island
experiment just to get me to realize
that i'm [ __ ] sitting outside a
coffee shop with a [ __ ] hat on
yeah
i've got 14 scarves
there was a makeup lady too we had like
just a crazy makeup lady oh [ __ ] wait
did she wear a shirt and makeup that was
like the joker like
the lipstick would literally be like
like just like a smiley face on it and
then it was just like crazy weird colors
on the face and you know like walking
along and always like wearing some sort
of like a
almost like a like a [ __ ] costume like
like a tiny shirt like a leopard fur
jacket and she's just waddling around
just covered it was nuts yeah
there's a couple of nuts that's scary
it's that scary that's like mrs dinsmore
from i i think ireland's great
expectations yeah but the problem is i
think ireland doesn't take much for us
to put you in put you away oh really new
york's similar i think ireland has a
very very easy oh you're saying if
you're crazy you get they they yeah
it wouldn't take much july
i feel some of the arguments that you
guys have had was probably enough for
you to be like listen this guy
yeah this guy's bonko's yeah this guy
what's the slip of the lip this guy
prepares coors light get this
you're in a home yeah
that's my endurance beer we had a
guy's a celebrity growing up howard he
went to high school with us he was older
he was special needs but he was always
the basketball manager the football
manager all that kind of stuff and he
would always ride his bike around and
anytime anybody sees him you know yo
howard yeah and he'd always yell back
yeah yeah i love that small town oh he's
great i saw him recently too he's still
out there kicking it it's good [ __ ] yeah
shout out to howie shout out to him
hallie if you're out there doing the
patreon
get a couple bucks together come see us
kylie t what do you got what do you got
coming up what do you want the kids to
know plug dave let's plug the page yeah
obviously come over to um the column
turtle
you obviously come up to the column
turtle podcast uh that's available
everywhere on youtube
it's just youtube forward slash column
turo and i'm doing some road gigs right
now with uh dad me
of those boys friends
mr rainey nice gentleman yeah so we've
got dates coming up in buffalo philly uh
detroit cleveland
houston austin
north carolina indianapolis and we're
adding much more so and
they're available just follow me on
social media at colin turtle you can get
tickets for that but more importantly
just come over check out the podcast the
boys were just on it we had a great
episode we had a great time and you're
cruising along to devein the highest
rate of the water hear that listen if
you're out there i don't care if you
watch this bozo show i'm kidding go
juice the number number one vid baby
what are we doing good we love that
obviously obviously i've got a patreon
too so if you have a couple of nickels
to help me pay off
uncle sam
he's really you know he's he's he went
out on a limb he's doing it himself he's
doing you know he's following our
footsteps [ __ ] go support him go
watch it whatever watch subscribe please
do it thank you buddy we love you thank
you so much appreciate it kevin what do
you got for him uh guys we're on the
[ __ ] road we're coming california
california alley nice uh san fran la oh
sf i apologize sf la uh la jolla and
then obviously we're gonna be a
pittsburgh buffalo detroit
chicago rosemont uh denver salt lake
city
what's the other one on that phoenix and
we're adding more dates ireland denver
i just said denver i got them all nice
gonna be in cali in a couple of weeks
come out and see us we're gonna have a
good [ __ ] time
gang we love you we'll see you next week